Mike do you think do you think the
record the Killer Instinct concept right
you know certain people have a Killer
Instinct then you'll see them like you
you know Celtics beat the Sixers right
and you've seen all the fans over there
you're seeing all the Sixers fans and
you're seeing who the Sixers fan who the
Celtics fans are they're like these guys
are dogs right like you can tell they're
tough guys right New York DNA right yes
you see certain people like there's a
certain level of toughness and
ruggedness and fearlessness right that
comes from it do you think the the
Killer Instinct folks in business in
politics in sports do you think they
need a little bit of that craziness
experience to go through or not
necessarily in all cases it depends on
the consequences that you're willing to
accept
what do you mean by that you know by
having that Killer Instinct the title
wanting one and one there's
repercussions to that
you know there's lawsuits there's people
that want to ruin your career they might
want to hurt your family you know it's a
lot of people
um repercussions that come with being
the dog the Beast animal the universe
tests you
did you did you watch are you into
movies or no do you like kind of have
you watched the new movie air the story
of Michael Jordan they keep telling me
you gotta watch it Ben Affleck no I
watch it I watch it have you seen it yet
or not I haven't seen it
oh Mike you gotta watch it because
there's a scene in the movie
were Sunny so we took 60 of our
employees here and we took 150 of our
insurance agents in Dallas and I want to
watch I watched it three times in two
weeks it's an incredible movie there's a
scene in the movie where Sonny is
sitting there talking to Michael okay
it's when Nike's making the pitch to
Michael to come to us and Michael
doesn't want to go to Nike he wants to
go to Adidas and he wants to go to all
these things
and he's saying Michael I'm just going
to get right into it he says look no
one's going to remember us they're going
to remember you he says we're all just
people in your life but long term here's
what's going to happen to you here's
what America is good at you're going to
go up there you're going to win you're
going to win a lot of championships
you're going to win MVPs you're going to
do this you're going to do that but then
the media is going to turn on you
there's going to be some losses there's
going to be some setbacks and he's while
he's explaining this he shows when his
dad dies in the movie they show when
he's losing they show when he's in the
Chicago White Sox and he's missing the
ball they show all of these things where
the the idea my dad told me this when I
was 16 years old says one thing about
America you know as an immigrant this
guy my dad's wisdoms you'll meet him
today when we're having lunch you you'll
need my dad so he said in America this
is what they'll do he says if they want
to turn you into a hero they'll turn you
into a hero but if they want to turn you
to see you fall America loves a fall but
what America even loves more than a fall
is redemption and a comeback it's such
an interesting thing about America what
happens to the great one so you know a
story like yours when you're talking
about the consequences you're willing to
face
um it's an interesting perspective when
you think about it Tom Brady do you you
see a Killer Instinct than a guy like
that right but he was raised in a
good family environment right you if you
watch man in the arena mom dad you know
three older sisters
you wonder like is the Killer Instinct
DNA is the Killer Instinct life
experiences is the killer it's the
choice it's interesting that you say
that because
um
we know some athletes that's number one
and probably the best in the world in
Europe their families are billionaires
but their families can't buy that spot
I'm being the best they can't buy
so it's not money it's the desire to win
it's so it's the individual you're yeah
normally when people
um are siblings of people that wealthy
they want to differ they want to um
pretty much
they want their own identity then
sometimes they change their names
because they want their own identity
they have their own self-worth
like I want to stay on this too to just
ask this question from him when he
became the youngest heavyweight okay and
we're all watching like oh my God you
know they called it cuss called it these
longest heavyweight everybody's losing
their minds right 20 20 years old 21
years old youngest ever heavyweight
champion
did that automatically attract other
goats that wanted to be around you who
were the champions and if it did which
I'm assuming it did because we've seen
pictures with you pretty much with
everybody
did you notice a similarity between your
wife where you're like oh I see I see
Michael oh I see magic oh I see Gretzky
oh I see Ali or ice man I kind of see a
little bit of myself in very interesting
how we have these two three things in
common did you see that yourself or you
weren't looking at it from that lens no
because
I really look at it not from um if I'm
if I may be permitted to say I just
think that people from that perspective
it's just ordained by God
that happened like that and it's not
necessarily because we're athletes or
entertainers there are people who are
the um pretty much
ordained by God to be the greatest
businessman to be the greatest garbage
man it's just it's all from the universe
and we have nothing to do with it but
just putting in the effort
interesting so it's a form of a
you know being chosen or being called
type of a thing pretty much I think I
think because custody summoned me
you know I'm I'm gonna meet this old
Italian guy
maybe he was like
wow you know Patrick most guys from the
street that came up the hard way they
fold not many guys make no
no you know you it's something within
you that makes you overcome that you got
to have a drive a determination because
most guys that come up like that they're
gone
a mentor a great mentor I had a good the
best mentor and the planet
nobody could do just do to me what he
could nobody it's never no one he was
the greatest
nobody can make me reach
myself
do you in your house or your office or
you know do you have a picture of them
absolutely what's your favorite picture
of you and him
um me hugging them after a fight or is
it is it no yes for taking a picture so
it's a it's a picture you have no we
haven't seen so it's not a public
picture I'm sure I've been thinking yeah
got him that's cool to you know it's
uh which one is that do you see it is
that the one on the right in front of
the white building no we'll go back you
I saw it yeah it was that day it's that
day no movement go back it just you had
it go back it's too far too far to the
right all the way to the right right
there uh oh eighteen there it is that
one right there and he's like get that
off me he hates it man what are you
doing get off that's your favorite
picture yeah it's like get oh stop he's
looking like intimacy he doesn't like
that stuff he's too hard what do you
think about when you see that picture
um he was right I'm the greatest ever
wow
he was right
Pat you bring up the Tom Brady thing and
yeah obviously Tom Brady and Mike Tyson
had a complete differing upbringing not
even a question
um but one thing they did have was a
chip on their shoulders so you bring up
Tom Brady drafted in the seventh round
189th pick you see the picture of when
he was drafted he didn't even look he
looked like he was just some frat dude
his sisters with a good athlete exactly
right so put a chip on his shoulder you
look at MJ the you know as The Story
Goes cut from his high school basketball
team holy [__] that just basically wound
him up he turned it you look at Kobe
when you interviewed Kobe what happened
with Kobe he was number 40 something on
the top
100 list of uh high school basketball
players boom he developed a kill list so
it's yeah there's the picture of Tom
Brady doesn't look like the goat right
there does he no turned out to be the
greatest quarterback to ever live
there has to be some even with you with
business when he went to the Army and
they told you that you would never be
nothing in your life your teachers you
got a 1.8 GPA you developed a chip on
your shoulder that said all right I'm
gonna turn this thing around so Mike
what was it for you I I completely
understand that cost was your uh is your
motivation everything that but you must
have had a chip on your shoulder what
was it that basically inspired you to
say all right let me turn my life around
and make this happen oh no I even know
this in order to be in math you first
have to be a fool and then after that it
works out
you first have to be a fool yeah okay
what does that mean
make mistakes and don't get them
discouraged it's so easy to get
discouraged and give up
this is kind of what Mike yeah I've been
knocked out before the average I had
nothing came easy for me I didn't give
up
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
foreign